il y aura bonsoir bonsoir alors avant de
passer à la question plus personnelle je
veux être demandé si à ton avis tu crois
qu'il existe une association pour aider
les gens à décrocher du minitel rose
c'est de l'info que c'est de l'intox
non je pense que c'est de l'info est ton
nouvel album s'appelle le col de la
croix morand et les gens ils voient chez
toi tu es quelque chose que fumer
peut-être on a parlé de col de l'utérus
c'est moi qui ai parlé de colle de 8,75
à bien précis d'ailleurs pour le
l'anglais avec qui j'ai travaillé sur le
sur le clip pour lui préciser quelle
était l'idée caché qu'il y avait
derrière le col de la croix mans je suis
simplement envoyer un message en lui
disant col de l'utérus
ça lui était très utile sera alors tu as
la considération des spécialistes la
considération du grand public mais tu
attends quand même un retour de bâton
comme tu dis pourquoi tu vas parler de
jeter comme un kleenex tu dis non je
pense que le succès ou le relatif succès
ça amène
rapport pornographiques avec les médias
donc la force d'être pris tous azimuts
et volontairement on se fait jeter on
peut pas être impunément à la fin de
tout le monde
un même pas un peu tapis toyer sûr
content quand même c'est ma spécialité
ouais chacun le stand va très bien
chacun un siège je prends toujours
autant de copies toujours autant ouais
j'ai dit à la campagne en auvergne
est-ce que tu soutiens les jacqueries de
paysans qui est un peu partout en france
en ce moment comme sûr je suis à fond
pour tout à fait
tout en conseillant le danger d'un ultra
régionalisme un nationalisme
d'ailleurs c'est un peu l'échec des
socialistes d'ailleurs eu d'avoir laissé
là la campagne en jachère propre et au
figuré
ce qui fait que l'extrême droite
récupère habilement et que le message
la terre c'est le pen passe très très
bien avec l'emploi n'y est pas derrière
tu dis que tu as peur d'être attirés par
les par les valeurs de la terre par les
dix mêmes les valeurs de l'occupation
bien sûr cette menace bien sûr non mais
c'est un danger pour tout le monde ça
s'est passé comment avec mylène farmer
très bien très bien très agréable jeune
fille et pour le partage des droits ça
s'est passé comment après dans la
difficulté mais j'étais assez normal
j'ai fait 55 ans annoncée al-qaïda
changement tant attendu nouvel album de
robert wyatt
ouais t'as plus on aime wyatt on est
moyen évident ce que je trouve un peu
ridicule c'est que c'est pas 100
meilleurs albums que le précédent était
bien supérieur il ya un engouement
hypocrite de la presse sur royal pains
faisait album est un album pour amiens
en fait qu'à nous on aime le calme
merci